100 clickbait title I'll admit to that
and I give absolutely no apologies
no I haven't been banned this is more of
a reference to all of the crying that
I've been seeing over the last day or so
maybe it's because I'm just feeling a
little bit sassy or perhaps I'm just
sick of hearing about all the classic
drama queens of the division two YouTube
scene having a cry about this but I
thought I'd throw together a quick video
on my own thoughts around this recent
punishment being dished out across the
community and why I'm glad it was done
I'm pretty slow at getting videos out by
the time I get this out it could have
been days but basically on the 4th of
July the official division Twitter
account posted this
wrapping it up because reading it word
for word seems like a massive waste of
your time users had found an exploit
that allowed them to gain insane amounts
of XP and shd watch levels it was done
through playing descent and having
players join up to another player
already running through
I've heard reports of people who are
gaining 50 levels or more in less than
10 minutes
people were literally gaining one to two
hundred thousand shd levels in less than
a week
so you can't tell me that these people
didn't know exactly what they were doing
as a result the dev team has said that
they will be taking appropriate action
in accordance with their policies
first-time offenders will receive a
two-week suspension and will have all
illegitimate progression rolled back
on top of this sanctioned players will
be flagged and any further exploitation
down the line AKA cheating will result
in a permanent ban
personally I am very happy with this
news the rollback is perfect and having
accounts flag for future abuse is the
best way they could have handled this
but why are people so upset about this
well the most simple answer is they got
caught
but there have been a lot of reposted
one-liners around why they think they
shouldn't be penalized
the divs coded into the game ban the
divs we're just playing what we've been
allowed to do
players will act like humans they will
find the fastest way to gain XP
why is this a problem let people do it
this game is dying why push people away
why do they not just shut down that part
of the game until it's fixed
but the summit level 10 exploit didn't
get anyone banned
I'll address each of these separately
but people need to remember the games
are far more complicated now than they
used to be and this particular team is
running on a very small crew gone are
the days of playing a PS1 game and then
looking up cheat codes that were
programmed into the game
this is a live service game while you
think it's only affecting you it really
isn't
starting with the easiest example that
everyone has pointed out these Mass
levels being gained will give an unfair
advantage in PvP because every level
gives a certain amount of Health boost
but even from a PVE point of view seeing
a player running around with 650 000
levels and knowing that they cheated to
get it isn't particularly motivating
towards players who are playing the game
legitimately after all at this stage the
shd levels are the most clear way to
show the time you have put into the game
it's currently the only visual
representation of time spent
while it may not be perfect right now
it's true and if the in-game is
cheapened least people are going to
bother with it reducing the number of
players in the long term
exploits like these will only further
push people away if nothing is done and
the ones who say they're leaving because
of being rolled back these aren't
exactly the people this community needed
anyway
on that note thank you very much to the
people who sent through the clips of a
certain YouTuber who likes to wear a
dorky yellow rain jacket in game and
speaks at roughly 0.25 the speed of
normal humans
it was super entertaining to witness him
on the verge of tears because of this I
never thought I'd say this about one of
his videos but that was quality content
I've seen a lot of people say why didn't
they just shut down that part of the
game while this was happening until they
soldered it and this is a fair and super
simple solution but nothing with these
live surface games are that simple
I laugh every time I see some idiot
YouTuber give the whole why don't they
just fix it like this spiel I have a
background in software development but I
wouldn't even slightly assume that I
know anything about game development
I figured that it wasn't just simply
shut down because of one of two reasons
one there isn't actually that many
people abusing the exploit
or two there was far more to it than
just turning off the game mode
but what about the previous XP exploits
well there's no one banned for them
well to be fair nothing has been able to
gain XP like this exploit I see a lot of
references to the summit level 10
exploit but this was really only
slightly faster than gaining XP through
legitimate methods
if it wasn't causing performance issues
for other players they probably wouldn't
have removed it at all
I've never been shy about expressing my
thoughts on people who choose to use
exploits cheats x and spread leaks
particularly those in the content
creator space
maybe it's just my neurodiverse view on
the world people need to have some
integrity
don't expect it from YouTubers they're
just after your clicks yes I know how
ironic it is to say this but as games
begin to get more advanced and detailed
the little things you could get away
with back in the day actually have some
real world impact on other players and
their experience
if you are playing a live service game
treat it like a community
if you were caught speeding in the real
world would you be surprised if you
received a speeding ticket
would you complain that the car
manufacturer allowed you to reach those
speeds so they are the ones at fault
if you found a security floor in a
retail store would you steal and then
blame it on them if caught because they
didn't set up this store securely enough
I don't know this feels like just a
really stupid discussion at this point
at least to me anyway
and then you get caught you get punished
I don't think this is just a thing in
New Zealand but maybe someone can
correct me here
long story short the cheaters the
people who share the exploits across the
community
good call division team I fully support
this move
Ceci engine out
[Music]
foreign